[Musik]
hallo willkommen zu einem neuen blog ich
habe gedacht ich nehme euch jetzt mal
durch meinen aktuellen alltag mit ich
mache euch vielleicht auch ein bisschen
gute laune müssen auf andere gedanken
kommt auch bei uns ist krone natürlich
ein thema auch im blog ich weiß die
meisten könnte nicht dann auch sollen
sie denn machen es ist nunmal aktuellen
das betrifft nur jeden aus vor ich da
groß herum quatsche gibt's erstmal einen
leckeren kaffee natürlich haben sie auch
wieder mit am start
die uns immer was mit dem start des halo
auch stolz zu beanstanden besucher nicht
die laune verderben corona hier
ich habe aber in ihrem land heißt der
milchviehhaltung was anderes
er war eben englisch den jahren das war
aber bisher bietet ist auch schon das
dargestellt wird das ist gut gemacht
[Musik]
es gibt ab zum großhändler also keine
einkaufswagen sondern waren für unseren
shop wie gedacht das ist der einzige zu
dem wir noch persönlichen bank günstig
jetzt pinguine nicht so natürlich auch
jetzt bock auf kinder
aber meine burg letzten tagen in selbst
quarantäne habe ich nur süßes gefuttert
verlange weil es so schlimm des e
commerce tritt man wieder auf die bremse
und ernähre mich mal wieder halbwegs
gesund übrigens habe ich mir soeben aus
betrug habe ich selbst geschrieben und
zwar geht darum dass falls
gegebenenfalls eine ausgangssperre
durchgeführt wird das ich eben durch
durch den betrieb dass die
betriebsstätte hier und da ist das da
hab ich das restaurant schrieben die
betriebsstätte ist sich nicht an meinem
wohnort zum entleeren des briefkastens
und für verwaltungstätigkeiten auch hin
und wieder mal hinfahren muss in
regelmäßigen abständen gibt vielleicht
leute designen oder übertreibt er
richtig sind doch keine ausgangssperre
geben aber vor zwei wochen hatten auch
auf instagram auch niemand geglaubt dass
das soziale leben stillgelegt wird und
kinos und einkaufszentren sc3
geschlossen werden ich umarme ja meine
familie schon seit anfang januar nicht
mehr
wegen des virus also mein vater hat auch
mit der lunge schwierigkeiten warum soll
ich warum soll ich das risiko jetzt
erhöhen also wenn ich es noch verhindern
kann so easy peasy dann mache ich das
doch und halte mich an gewissen sachen
und wir sind auf jeden fall im shop
laden in sachen abschauen nach dem
rechten die mitarbeiter hat die sind
natürlich trotzdem weiterhin am arbeiten
wäre sorgen hier für ganz viel
desinfektions zeug beziehen sich
handschuhe an die achten auf jeden fall
auf sich und sie landet das mir die
sachen ab jetzt will ich hier im leeren
karton bahn rollwagen und ich habe mir
überlegt jetzt nämlich gerade im shop
und habe mir gedacht kommt mit kleine
verlosung ist auf jeden fall drin wenn
ich schon mal da bin und zwar verlor
sich etwas was ihr so im laden schwer
bekommen da habe ich gedacht gebe ich
drei leute von euch die chance also drei
meiner zuschauer kriegen jetzt die
chance dass hier zu gewinnen zweimal
jobs in weiß in weiß gibt's die nahezu
nirgends und das habe ich gedacht die
definitiv das sind back feste weiße
schoko chips
perfekt für meinen subway cookie und
zwei packungen von dem wandel der
extrakt alkoholfrei in der squeeze
flasche mega mega aromatisch genau
zweimal zu plätschern zweimal wurde
extrakt und darf man gibt jeweils drei
pakete das heißt insgesamt können drei
von euch dieses paket gewinnen was ihr
dafür tun müsst schreibt mir einfach in
die kommentare wie ihr auf meinen kanal
gekommen seid ganz easy einfach ein
kommentar hinterlassen außerdem wie die
last auf diesem video ein bisschen nach
oben es kostet euch gerade mal eine
halbe sekunde und seit abonnent meines
kanal 2 das gewinnspiel richtet sich
natürlich an meine treuen abonnenten in
der community und wo setzt weiter an die
arbeit und sehen was hier noch so fehlt
aktuell kümmere ich mich nämlich noch um
die bestellungen aber unser team wächst
auch gerade muss ich sagen also ich
krieg hier fleißig unterstützung je mehr
leute mir unter die arme greifen desto
mehr content kann sich produzieren das
heißt alles was dann hier nicht an
arbeit draufgeht an zeit drauf geht es
investiere ich natürlich in video sein
rezept entwicklungen als separaten ich
brauche andere nervennahrung und zwar in
form von dixon die haben wir aktuell so
gut wie immer den paketen drin
schmeckt so gut es schmeckt einfach so
frisch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
also das ist ja mal ein richtiges
blogger leben jaffé sich für nichts zu
schade und wieder daheim
wisst ihr was jetzt habe ich mir
verdient war fleißig und deswegen könne
nicht mit den jetzt leute bin ich
täglich seit man ehrlich bitte sagt mir
dass irgendjemand gibt der ein pinguin
auch ab und zu so ist erst mal die
seiten abknabbern ich kann es mit einer
hand nicht demonstrieren aber dann nimmt
man die oberklasse ab und hat hier nur
noch dieses shooting dann hat man nur
noch die seite ich zelebriere es halt
richtig ist es nicht so wie du haben wir
ein bisschen nach dem anderen und das
ding weg geatmet
richtig schön zelebrieren versuchen
selbst war ich gerade leicht mit euch
auf instagram und ich habe mir ja nur im
live
diese dieses album let getroffen gemacht
und fiel zum schluss um darauf haben
sich am ende doch noch entschieden hat
das produkt mit dazu kann natürlich das
läuft halbe stunde ich habe so lange
gebraucht bei den kärnten livestreams
marken sind abgelenkt aber essen wir
erstmal ne also hört verhöre und viele
mannschaft bauen
die anzeige ist raus
deutschland hätte setzung weil man hier
so spät ist dann ist habe ich ein
problem damit du also ich mag keine
überhänge und also brauchst du mich
diese laden geht so nicht er war schluss
mit lustig aber wenn ich hier gewinnen
sollte dies jetzt ins bett ich gebe mich
jetzt einmal abschminken zähneputzen
pyjama an und dann schlafen ich würde
mich aber noch ganz kurzes boller zeigen
ich habe ihm bleibt schon so ein
bisschen angeteasert dass wir ein paar
neue produkte haben insbesondere was so
deko und babyartikel am ramadan geht
natürlich auch außerhalb ramadan ist
aber irgendwie war mir das so sein
bedürfnis da auch so ein paar teile
speziell von ramadan anzubieten weil man
dann einfach echt also ich bin in diesem
monat total in der orient schiene mega
weil auch alles was ich koche mir ein
orientalisches buffet forsthaus und hier
tisa ich euch mal ein produkt so das ist
ein produkt sieht halt mega orientalisch
aus es geht auch außerhalb ramadan das
ist halt mega mega mega hochwertig und
ich finde die farbe so toll sie habe
aber auch insgesamt drei farben aber das
seht ihr dann das wird ein spoiler und
den restlichen seht ihr dann wenn es
soweit ist ich will euch natürlich auf
instagram informieren so hier schon
alles dunkel ich war ziemlich jetzt und
wir sehen uns morgen wohl wieder gute
nacht
morgen so ein hallo aus der küche ich
mache mir jetzt erstmal komplett haben
sogar 1 genau wie wir es nicht viele in
diesem haushalt aber zeit lang gesamt
und auf jeden fall gibt es dann auch
noch kaffee und dann starten wir jeden
tag drehen und haben kurze 15 minuten
pause weil meine mutter masse abkühlen
muss
und ja da kann man so lange warten
einfach mit kaffee zwischenzeit übrigens
habe ich jetzt nicht mehr den
vollautomaten weil ich einfach fand dass
die nicht immer sehr kalt war
obwohl ich in fallout man immer gewartet
habe gereinigt hab ich hab' ich habe da
echt alles an die pflege gemacht daran
kann es nicht liegen und dann habe ich
online gelesen dass viele das problem
haben und deswegen habe ich die nicht
mehr unterdessen haben wir eine einer
siebträgermaschine und jetzt habe ich
auch ein bisschen übungen man braucht
auch ein bisschen übung dafür so ein
bisschen einführung und dann klappt das
und jetzt mache ich mir darin immer
meinen kaffee und zelebriere letzte mal
total
[Musik]
die brownies sind im backofen und ich
muss jetzt gucken was was koche ich
heute das letzte was ein talent
hochhalten
mal gucken ob dieser dieser wert in
dieser challenge ins leben gerufen
4 383 haben
[Musik]
okay ich habe mich auch an die challenge
versucht ihr wollt das ergebnis aber
nicht sehen habe ich auf instagram
gepostet übrigen fragt noch vielfach in
sydney
das ist voll die bereicherung weil sie
dem us dollar da könnt ihr mit
entscheiden was bald kommt und und und
und jetzt zeige ich euch mal das
endergebnis von unserem heutigen video
[Musik]
cooking time jetzt habe ich gerade aus
dem tiefkühler man hat falsch geholt ich
habe gerade gemerkt dass ich mega viel
hackfleisch eingefroren hab ich erinnere
mich noch ich hatte eingekauft beim
metzger aber dann zu müde habe einfach
alles in einen gefrierbeutel getan jetzt
habe ich ungefähr ein kilo
das heißt es reicht erstmal für heute
und morgen und was ich mache das friere
ich dann auch noch einen für irgendein
dritten tag um lassen
[Musik]
müsste in kombination mit reis ich liebe
es so sieht das dann aus maine tiefkühl
blätterteig taut gerade an und die sind
ja eigentlich relativ dick und relativ
klein und deswegen nehme ich mir noch
nudelholz und macht die einfach so ein
bisschen flacher man könnte auch
manchmal könnte man auch echt meint ich
bin nicht schwanger
ich wollte eigentlich auch so oberteile
tut man da denkt man sofortige keystone
im vierten monat aber muss auch sagen
die quarantänezeit macht dick wir sind
nur am essen
ich trinke am tag irgendwie doppelt so
viel kaffee gesund sich erste viele
süßigkeiten zwischendurch mittagessen
nehme ich mir noch einen zweiten teller
sind welche kleine frage antwort runde
machen ich habe nämlich auf instagram
fragen sammelt die erste frage lautet
seid ihr von corona virus betroffen
social media viele meinen ja das
instagram blogger youtuber gar nicht
betroffen sind von corona virus war sich
als online abspielt bei uns das ganze
ein bisschen anders wir haben ja auch
unseren online shop
da besteht zu anderen aber es läuft
natürlich alles of line up die ganze
abwicklung des bestellen bei den
händlern etc
in solchen zeiten bin ich einfach nur
stolz darauf daß meine kiki produkte
meine eigenen produkte zu 99 prozent in
deutschland hergestellt werden und ich
da also dahin geht keine lieferengpässe
haben werde ich habe nicht das problem
dass die aus china angeliefert werden
müssen oder generell aus dem ausland
natürlich habe trotzdem produkte im shop
die aus dem ausland kommen das ist
unvermeidlich man arbeitet aber daran
dass man sich immer weiter und weiter
entwickelt und so viele produkte wie
möglich dann auch selber herstellen
lässt dort wo man es eben am liebsten
herstellen lassen möchte wir arbeiten da
getroffen und gibt es erst seit einem
jahr den online-shop jubiläum hanser
müssen monster aktion einfallen lassen
könnten wir haben wir in die kommentare
schreiben was wir uns für eine aktion
einfallen lassen sollen für den job
[Musik]
nein ich 50 prozent rabatt lasst uns
noch etwas leben ja auf jeden fall sind
wir trotzdem betroffen weil es bei allen
herstellern trotzdem lieferengpässe geht
werden aber gut vorgesorgt und abgesehen
vom online shop ist jetzt aber auch ein
großprojekt abgesagt bzw verschoben
worden und ich kann euch nicht so viel
darüber erzählen es gibt ja bei
kooperationen mit verträgen immer
verschwiegen heitz klauseln aber es wäre
ein super cooles projekt gewesen mit
einer 4 markt dessen produkte ich
eigentlich schon seit ich denken kann
bei mir im schrank habe und deswegen
habe ich mich so darauf gefreut aber es
ist wahrscheinlich nur verschoben in
dieser richtung das ding ist was
eigentlich aktuell nur haben so und ich
wissen ist dass wir mit dem also mit den
einnahmen dieses großprojekt ein anderes
großprojekt starten wollten zum ende des
jahres
davon weiß trainer hat noch keiner das
behalte ich auch erstmal für mich ist
das ein projekt von hass das projekt was
ihr glaube ich nicht so erwarten würde
aber das ist ja auch noch nicht
aufgehoben also aufgeschoben ist nicht
aufgehoben sagt man das so ja das halt
ein bisschen schade aber gesundheit geht
immer vor das war ein projekt wie viel
reisen würden mit dieser firma und
schade aber ist nun mal so packte die
pakete im shop selber nein das haben wir
in den ersten wochen natürlich gemacht
in den ersten monaten haben sie erst in
wochen oder monaten monate wir haben es
am anfang auf jeden fall selber gemacht
und haben gemerkt dass also es geht
nicht mehr wir machen videos ich mache
immer noch die bestellung werden also
die händler bestellungen ich guck
natürlich was beim e book shop
aufgenommen wird aber das verpacken an
sich das machen unsere mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter und die sind darauf so
fleißig die verpackten das mit ganz viel
liebe und ich glaube das merkt ja auch
wenn ihr dann einen kick paket öffnet
wohnt ihr zur miete oder ist das
eigentum das hier ist eine mietwohnung
eigentum so weit sind wir noch nicht
natürlich ist es in zukunft ein traum
aber das dauert halt alles noch ein paar
jährchen aktuell ist es so dass wir
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr platz
gebrauchen können
weil ich habe kein richtiges wohnzimmer
ich habe keinen platz für ein esstisch
ich kann nie die ganze familie auf
anrufen also meine schon ich habe ja nur
drei geschwister aber anders familie zum
beispiel alle auf einmal zu rufen das
wäre dann alles zu eng und zu chaotisch
und daher hoffe ich dass das nächste
projekt klappt nämlich das drüben auf
der anderen seite die räumlichkeit frei
wird und wir dann das anmieten können
durchbruch machen um unsere wohnung so
erweitern hier quasi der seite hätten
wir da noch einmal ein schönes
wohnzimmern großes mit esstisch und
nochmal extra raum das als büro nutzen
könnten dann würden wir das jetzige
arbeitszimmer zum ankleidezimmer
verwandeln bei unser schlafzimmer auch
sehr klein ist und wie aktuell zwei
schränke in zwei verschiedenen räumen
haben es ist etwas kompliziert wer macht
den haushalt hamza oder du immer alles
ich meine ein spaß
hanser hilft mir haben wir hilf mir
ungemein der so viel zu tun ich auch wie
zu tun aber wir müssen uns da
gegenseitig unterstützen damit wir nicht
im chaos versinken wir benutzen da
unsere küche tagtäglich bei einer
tagtäglich zum filmen und generell auch
tagtäglich und die küche mit dem
wohnzimmer zusammen wir haben einen
großen flur der angrenzend ist alles
offen und alles was offen ist nicht
automatisch immer unordentlich aus ist
sie muss man immer die ordnung behalten
haben sie saugt immer ganz toll der
rücken die spülmaschine ein und aus was
machst du noch alles sagt er noch ein
paar sachen damit sie besser rüberkommt
trägt den müll raus ja
gibt s night unter youtube also es gibt
ja verschiedene bereiche es gibt ja
gaming beauty dann gibt es eben backen
und kochen ich kann nur über meinen
bereich sprechen ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen wie es in anderen bereichen
das gefühl dass die beauty blogger immer
alles und mega harmonisch miteinander
sind weil der markt eben groß genug ist
genauso ist es auch beim backen und
kochen bin ich der persönlichen meinung
dass jeder sein stück kuchen abhaben
darf aber trotzdem gibt es das auch in
meiner branche sag ich mal
ihr müsst aber immer unterscheiden
zwischen neid und missgunst neid ist ja
ist ja einfach ein gefühl wenn jemand
sagt das möchte ich auch haben und
missgunst ist finde ich noch eine stufe
schlimmer weil das ist so ein gefühl da
denkt man sich ich will das auch haben
und du solltest aber nicht haben das
heißt jemand denkt sich nein das ist nur
für mich bestimmt und du darfst das
nicht haben und ich bin immer der
persönlichen meinung der markt ist groß
genug es gibt genug kuchenstücke für
alle und daher bin ich bei diesem thema
also ich persönlich bin mega mega sie
darauf konzentriere mich hier oft meine
geschichte und trotzdem bekomme ich in
solchen bereichen auch das ein oder
andere mit was ich aber nicht möchte ist
irgendwie öffentliches bloßstellen et
cetera
also er sollte auf meine seite finden um
und dazu kommen zu entspannen
inspiration zu sammeln und daher
vermeide ich jetzt doch tiefer in diese
thematik einzugehen machte wieder eine
ramadan reihe ich bekomme diese frage
total häufig ich habe schon ein paar mal
erwähnt natürlich gibt es wieder eine
ramadan reihe geht in die vierte runde
und ich liebe die ramadan reihe ich
liebe dich zelebriert das richtig ich
bin ein bisschen traurig weil letztes
jahr haben wir kurz vom rama lang weise
gerne geheiratet dann sind wir umgezogen
da machen alle so ein bisschen stressig
und ich konnte das gar nicht so
zelebrieren wir haben natürlich trotzdem
unsere reihe durchgezogen alle drei tage
gab es ein neues video das waren hohes
pensum und es hat mir riesenspaß gemacht
aber ich war ein bisschen unter druck
muss ich sagen dieses jahr möchte ich
das unbedingt vermeiden
ich möchte endlich den ramadan genießen
ich genieße das auch in form von rezept
videos für euch filme aber ich möchte
auch wirklich so ein bisschen zeit
finden um so diese spirituelle zu
erleben also letztes jahr kam es nicht
zu kurz und das ist hängt noch so in mir
drin ich muss es dieses jahr unbedingt
aufholen und deswegen gehen wir jetzt
die tage schon ganz entspannt an die
rezepte schon mal zu drehen die hälfte
an was folgen drehen bevor ramadan und
die andere hälfte tragen wir während
ramadan nehmen wir euch wieder beim
fastenbrechen mit beim fcz
also es wird auf jeden fall richtig
schön und ich bin auch der meinung dass
ich auch ganz viele andere back blogger
oder back youtuber dazu ermutigt habe
ramadan reihe zu machen weil mir
aufgefallen dass ja damals das gemacht
immer mal sporadisch und das video aber
jetzt sind es richtige ramadan reihen
geworden
das gefühl man glücklicher so ein
bisschen mehr ins zeug auch für unser
fest klar weihnachten ostern etc es
kommt auch alles nicht zu kurz hier auf
youtube deutschland aber hamann das ist
jetzt echt so ein bisschen halt das
gefühl durch uns ein bisschen
aufgeschlossen sagt man das so auf jeden
fall freut mich das so ich würde mal
sagen ich verabschiede mich so langsam
so langsam komme ich zum ende des rocks
versuche wieder regelmäßiger zu werben
ohne mich als werden du hast ja sie
fragen beantworten
sorry das ist nicht der der möglichkeit
hier in gefahr bringt nichts ein neues
lichtlein wechselt überla kind noch so
nicht anders ausgefallen aber dadurch
müsste wenn es so warm ist so ein
bisschen weiterhin gehen damit man das
umschaut business ist aber nichts war
sehr groß hat ich habe alles im beruf
hat gehört eine ganze unterhaltung mit
den leuten macht spart sechs gespräch
ich finde es schöner sport interessant
da einfach jemand selbstgespräche führt
ich mag da ja ich gehe wohl auch
beteiligt also ganz ehrlich weniger als
fragwürdig er bekommt ja ich trinke viel
wasser trinkt hier wasser abwasser leute
bringen das ist die halbe hecht wasser
trinkt heute gesund ist die halbe miete
stimmt geht nicht raus genauer aus wir
bleiben zu hause an einem genau punkt
unsere videos dann nicht richtig
produziert content damit ihr zuhause
bleibt ja so lautlos wird ja übertrieben
ärzten abgeordneter platz wäre okay bis
zum nächsten video hinterlassen auf
jeden fall einen kommentar
[Musik]